but take a look at how this changes our
diagram in the old version we had only
one function object because it had been
defined outside of the car like function
now as a result of the fact that we
moved the source code for that move
method up into the body of the car like
function we now have a new function
being generated every time we run the
car like function this is a high price
to pay for the simplicity of having all
of your code show up at the same level
of indentation inside the body of the
car like function people are often
confused why it would be the case that
moving the function definition up into
the body of this function would result
in there being many move methods many
different function objects one per
instance of a car let's open a new file
to examine that point the simple maker
function builds and returns a brand new
object so after calling make an object
twice and storing each of the results in
a variable do you expect the two objects
that are stored in these two variables
to be the exact same or to be two
objects that look quite similar because
of the similarities in their properties
another way of asking this is would they
pass a strict comparison of their
identity using triple equals